people had to leave Germany and we never
had many people who were leaving Germany
to come to Holland and nobody really was
prepared everybody's about it won't
happen to Holland it's happening in
Germany but it won't happen here ii
didn't answer them very well and we like
talent very much and so perhaps no
Holland was very liberal and hospitable
country it was foreigners and I was
threatening towards true
truths and had a tradition of being poor
Jewish and we went to a non-jewish
school and it was a very happy time in
my life between 34 and 40 this was where
these were the happiest years of my
childhood
we were assimilated into the culture I
mean I never thought that I was Jewish
I was Dutch the world war for cotton my
decision Holland was neutral and Holland
was traditionally neutral also in the
first world war Holland was not involved
in in the war and the majority of the
Jewish people in Holland did not really
come to grips with a potential danger
they said they didn't think of a German
invasion to Holland and the war started
made a tense we were woken up know very
early in the in the morning and you have
carried accounts from that far and wide
there was a fantastic beautiful day the
apple blossoms were in bloom as they
never had bloomed up beautifully in our
garden and we heard these the birthing
of the airplanes and at first we thought
that they were just the maneuvers
exercises but then the worst is you know
at the aircraft from the Hook of Holland
which is at the end of the waterway from
Rotterdam
to the North Sea you could see that they
were shooting and all these puffs of the
shells bursting in the air I was 16
years old and I remember that I was so
kind of irate and excited that that
somebody would just you know invade your
country without any pretext nothing
whatsoever the large amount of German
army would but pulled into Holland with
with with huge convoys of trucks and and
and and soldiers just standing there
hanging around and and I don't think as
a kid I realized you know what what this
whole thing until meant what the
seriousness of this this whole thing is
what what really I think impressed me
the most was did that animals that I saw
laying in the fields and and the
destruction that bombs really do at that
stage actually people hope that somehow
life will return back to a normal
routine was in you know understand
German occupation of course rationing
all this kind of thing started and the
first year was a year of again evasion
and
flight from home reality but doing that
year the German the Germans actually
they told up how to organise the
extinction of the Jewish community Jews
in Holland like they did not in the
other occupied countries the first step
was that all Jews had to register Jews
could only couldn't use public
transportation anymore could only shop
between 2:00 and 4:00 in the afternoon
there was curfew at 8:00 radios had to
be were collected from Jews but they
were very clear regulations that every
Jew had to so not not was a pin to saw
on his Colt or on his race or on his
jacket the Jewish yellow star and I'll
never forget the first day when we had
to go into the street with this star and
everybody's looking at us and at that
time the Dutch population part of the
Dutch population out of identification
they put on them some many people
themselves sister and there were lots of
manifestations of identification of the
Dutch population with the fate of the
Jews and this was a great source of
support and the day when this law was
passed that we had to discontinue - - as
Jewish students to attend his school the
director assembled all the students the
rector of the school said with all the
students and gave a great speech in
support of the Jewish students and
against this law and very very very
supportive and from this year 1942 every
year we got a birthday card into the
concentration camps during the night one
always could hear you know remember
there was a curfew and one could hear
the trucks went around collecting people
and in the morning one heard this one
was arrested in this one was arrested
Germans were just closing up ten blocks
square and coming in with their trucks
and had Jews for master work young
fellows carrying the people out what
they brought to Amsterdam and what the
density of the weight was and they knew
right away if in one day like twenty
kids so ten kids disappeared that was a
raid but if three kids didn't come they
were in hiding and the way those Germans
treated those children again on a sunny
day like today at nine o'clock in the
morning you're on your way to work and
you see on the sidewalk adult males
laughing and joking around while they're
picking up small children by their their
arms their legs their hair and throwing
them in a truck it helps you believe
that they could do anything at all there
were two women who attacked the Germans
tried to stop them
and they were thrown on the truck too
and that was when I decided to become
more active shall we say
when I walked on on the street became a
priest came to me city how do you think
you can save your life and I said the
only way that I can save that the Jewish
can save to life that do not Jewish
people take us in and that we get that
we are hidden and the next day my
English teacher came and he said I have
a place for you to go so I went with the
bicycle and we drove 70 kilometer and he
brought me to a woman but I know from a
hometown and I was hidden there I was
one of the last kids in my class that
went to hiding I went in 43 and I would
say we started with a class of 60 kids
and we were left maybe ten kids there
were different ways of going into hiding
there was an Frank's way where Anne
Frank's father had very carefully
arranged for these two rooms in his
factory to be occupied by himself his
wife his two daughters and four other
people and the Gentiles who supplied
them with food and clothing and used
from the outside world came in every day
or every other day or something like
that they did not live with them so
every season would pass by from winter
to spring from spring to summer and
summer to fall and fall to winter one
year after another and I was 14 I was 15
it was 16 and I never had any fun the
day of the week sometimes we did and
sometimes we didn't it was you know
sometimes they dependent very much we
would listen to radio Orange which was
underground we had a radio to us
underground and the farmer occasioning
would let us walk were listened and then
at 6:00 o'clock at night it would be
radio orange from England and that was
only our way of knowing what was going
on in the world constantly being trapped
can't get out I'm stuck and if I go out
on the guilt so there was always a fear
the fear of never getting out never
mother ever getting out who knew was any
hope that we were going to survive one
was it hope that we ever would be
liberated we hoped but it went from year
to year I was very lonely and it was a
young girl and it was a very outgoing
girl and I was very sports minded and
and it was very locked up in the house
it couldn't go out at all anywhere and
run and not part of us whatever's hidden
was and that was in the bill that was
not far from ultra but another Jewish
family had been a lawyer a lemon life
and she say ready to come and visit this
family and I was very glad event there
and I didn't look so Jewish I could have
really go out for not Jewish and I went
there and when the moment I was there
the police came there was something very
frightening and uncertain and secure
about the whole atmosphere
I guess that's an understatement
considering that you have these people
dressed up in military uniform with big
rifles pointing at you and I remember
that we were rushed that we had didn't
have any time to get anything together
and then I remember we were taken in
some kind of a vehicle I guess it was a
truck to a place where many of the other
Jews were gathered
everybody in Holland at first - best of
all and from there they were central to
Germany no you got to Westerberg what
did you see a train made for me people
and people who live in the can we're
helping the people of the trains with
the children and then it was a mess but
first of all I think was or my memories
of it were still compared with what was
to come
not that it was normal but ok it was it
was not a death camp
and I guess my worst memory is a Vista
board was just the fearfulness of of
losing my mother and my father and also
you know the pervasive cold there was
just nothing to do with it was like a
prison yard really exactly what it was
and I guess today somebody would say I'm
bored there was just nothing to do and
it was filthy and one of the worst
things I remember the toilets work was
there were none they were basically an
outhouse with little holes my father
used to call them egg racks and we put a
dozen eggs in and with no discrimination
between male or female and I guess at
one point don't care anymore you know no
trauma to squeeze or anything it was
just no facilities whatsoever
so the my mother was having this
unending fight to try and keep us clean
which was hopeless but she kept trying a
lot of rats there and the rats at night
used to kind of run across your bed and
across your face Wester board was a
assembly camp from which the Jews were
deported for what they call resettlement
I don't remember speaking a lot to my
brother but I remember feeling always
very close to him and very protective it
was like two of us against the world my
father knew the trains of the East were
hopeless again no don't really want want
to believe what was half
but it was hard to ignore the evidence
and at some point you believe the rumors
and my father became convinced that any
any train to Treblinka Auschwitz or
Asian start was the end I guess anyone
who's been to the Holocaust remembers
trains and the life evolved around the
arrival and departure of trains and
invest aboard
I think the train was almost in the
middle of the street and came on the
same day every week I think it was
Tuesday or something the beginning of
the week I remember a lot of discussion
about you know trains and and the lists
and people being on the list and off the
list etc etc and that one day we were on
we were on the train this road isn't in
the freight train with perhaps 80 people
and straw on the floor and I think a
little bathroom and of some significant
bathroom hole that it would go through
that I think I don't know exactly
exactly
it was very bad no food and we grow
three days and three nights to that camp
we arrived in the middle of the night
which I think they did all the time
purposely and by this time you know when
you had to jump outside from middle
argument the only thing you heard in
this terrible confusion
a-rod's Harris lost lost and they stood
you in lines of five and I really I
didn't even realize it that you know
they were looking at us and that people
went this way that way I didn't realized
for me it was absolutely you know the
confusion was so terrible that I didn't
realize anything what was going on I
just knew I was holding on on one side
to my mother and the other side to my
sister and fortunately they nobody you
know nobody separated us so that so that
we burn and you know we were taken and
as we were walking in in this terrible
confusion with dogs and with German
officers all around they put us in a
line and they started to march us and in
this darkness and so all these lights I
mean things going on you know like they
had a fire really all around and but the
confusion was so terrible and all barbed
wires all around did you know where no I
didn't see I didn't see I didn't see a
sign saying gosh width I didn't know
that I was they just opened the place
and said harassed and jump out and leave
everything put everything just read
everything that and you will find it so
we but we had to get out dress and they
get shaved
all the body hair gets shaved and now we
had to take a shower shower then we get
leaked over the street to another
barrack and there's our people when I
was shaved them and he comes in around
the corner in the other hole and you see
all those bald people
I don't know all men I was new but now
you see it where women is so so terrible
but then I'm the eyes you recognize each
other all bolt
everybody nobody had just gonna shower
and all we had all I get was a cotton
dress without sleeves and about Buddha
shoes because all of my all my clothes
nothing else that was in November 44
to describe an inferno it's just it's
just impossible to describe the terror
the Dark Knight and their and the dogs
and the III felt frozen
I don't think it was possible it just it
just didn't seem possible it just
knocked on your consciousness and you
couldn't let it in
there was a screaming there was a the
couples in the end there was an insane
screaming you hear this in an insane
asylum and dogs barking and and and
these inhuman guys standing there and
children crying and and dark and the
next thing I it just it just couldn't be
it couldn't be understood it couldn't be
even incorporated it was the end of the
world I and my sister and my mother were
absolutely dazed I don't know how other
people were but we were it's like
somebody he died I don't even consider
it hit you over the head it's just
something that the disbelief of this
thing of a day an hour in Auschwitz like
it must be when people talk about you
know when you read Dante's description
of of Hell I think that really you must
have had a terrific imagination because
it was something close proximity even
worse
the gas the gas ovens were right nearby
and the smoke pushed out like an angry
fist day and night after three months we
were ten thousand in that camp after
three months those were preceded as we
guessed
so we knew when our turn came because
Germans are very orderly but if you had
a big shoelace and somebody was walking
around and their shoes were falling good
and I don't know what the piece of glass
or somebody got the spoon that he made
the chart and we could cut off a piece
of string and give to the next woman
that and she could tie her shoes and
look more presentable in the morning
because every morning were lined up on
the under place and the SS came and they
looked over and if somebody didn't look
good not that anybody looked good but if
somebody looked like you had to look you
have to stand up straight and you had
high and sure that you still you still
have the strength to work that they can
pump it out of you for another month or
two month and this was I think that that
woman gave me a lot of courage seeing
that there is because there were so many
people that they done great at you and
yet if you find somebody that could
encourage you could give you look up to
so you felt there's still good people
outside and we're gonna gonna look
through it I wanted to live I wanted to
know what married life is I mean I was
really we were philosophize with my
friend - his name is Rhea he's a
wonderful wonderful woman and my other
friend and we would sit in Auschwitz and
talking yeah we didn't really want to
get married to one another feeling what
it is to make love to a man wanna know
what the best to have a child the train
left our streets and they were playing I
remember wonderful music and the work
astronaut women Orchestra it was like a
very festive occasion except I catotti a
walk and and see I was dazed really how
long had you been there in arsh which we
were there about 2 months 2 months I
wasn't as I told me like this was
eternity
I remember being on this cattle car and
I remember it's just being dark and
crowded and the door being slammed and
no lights except whatever was comes to
the cracks and I don't know how many it
may have taken a couple of days that my
next vivid memory was was arriving at
bergen-belsen fetid Belsen near the end
that I didn't say very much and my
parents confirmed that that I very
rarely talked and I became at us asylum
swings and I think that part of it was
you know somehow all the strength was
taken from you and all that you could do
was silently watch what was happening
around you and there was just nothing
more to say or do
I remembered always walking running and
learning how to count on bodies but it
was perfectly unremarkable the bodies in
in the morning people were dead either
the person you slept with or they just
collapsed this was a constant kind of
thing people are literally dropping like
flies and it was totally unremarkable
because it was part of the existence
there I saw people dying around me
everywhere of hunger of illness I lived
and that perhaps I don't remember other
people telling me but I lived right
across from us with a charnel house
filled with corpses not just the inside
but overflowing all over they were
corpses all over I lived
walked beside that people and after a
while it just got to be so that one
noticed and one had to say to myself I'm
not going to see her with this
I'm not going to recognize anyone in
this person who is lying there and it
got to the point where I realized that I
had to close my eyes to a number of
thing
and otherwise I would not have survived
even at that time because I saw people
around me going mad I couldn't persuade
my sister to get off to get up my mother
wasn't getting up it was it was like the
end of the road then of course I
remember the mass graves and their
people just being thrown on these graves
and I remember that for a while there
there was a quota that a certain people
had to die every day or every week and
that if not enough people died that the
Germans felt that they had to take some
other measures and I remember a lot of
conversation about that because it's
Belsen even though it didn't have gas
chambers that was someone said it had
some kind of a well then I've got shame
was in had a crematorium but I mean it
was really a camp where most people
literally starved to death and
apparently they had as the records later
showed a very organized methodical
projections about after a certain amount
of months or years there would be nobody
left so it was seen I think the
pervasive feeling and all those camps
was that it was everybody's turn sooner
or later and it was just a matter of
when it was going to be your turn my
sister had thyroid and I saw the way she
suffered laying there because the dirt
there was no voter for the list for the
two weeks before the liberation and I
don't mean water to wash oneself water
to drink the hunger was an undescribable
way the deaths were piled up
that was so serendipitous and I think
there's any answer to why we survived
and other people died it was truly the
luck of the draw
you